Hey there, beautiful nerds! Last week a bunch of us from Radio Topia were on our West Coast tour and it was a blast. The illusionist Helen Zoltzman and I hosted the show, which features stories from criminal, the memory palace, mortified, the illusionist, the West Wing Weekly, and 99% invisible. For the 99Pi live story, we went back to my favorite writer and musical collaborators, John Muellum, and in this this incarnation the brink players but you know them as members of the Decemberists and Black Prairie. Performing this story in front of a live audience was a privilege unlike anything else I've ever done and I couldn't wait to share it with you. I hope you like it. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It was the middle of the night on March 27th 1964.
嘿，各位可爱的书呆子们！上周我们 Radio Topia 的一群人进行了西海岸巡演，真是太棒了。幻术师海伦·佐尔茨曼和我主持了这场演出，节目内容包括来自《Criminal》、《The Memory Palace》、《Mortified》、《The Illusionist》、《The West Wing Weekly》和《99% Invisible》的故事。为了《99% Invisible》的现场故事，我们找到了我最喜欢的作家和音乐合作者约翰·穆勒姆，以及这次的表演者——布林克剧团，但你们可能更熟悉他们作为 The Decemberists 和 Black Prairie 成员的身份。在现场观众面前表演这个故事是我做过最荣幸的事情，我迫不及待地想与你们分享。希望你们喜欢。这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。那是 1964 年 3 月 27 日的深夜。
Earlier that evening, the second biggest earthquake ever measured at the time, and insane 9.2 had mangled Anchorage, Alaska. 115 people died. Houses turned literally upside down or skidded into the sea. There was no light or power in the city, and for a long time, virtually no communication with the outside world. But there was radio. Are we on the air? Yes. We're ready to go again. It was a station in Anchorage running on backup generators and a cracked transmitter. The station in Fairbanks picked up that signal and repeated it. And a man in Juno somehow picked up that Fairbanks station called a radio station in Seattle and let
那天傍晚早些时候，当时测量到的史上第二大地震，一场 9.2 级的疯狂地震摧毁了阿拉斯加州的安克雷奇。115 人死亡。房屋被彻底颠倒或滑入海中。城市里没有灯光或电力，很长一段时间里，与外界几乎没有任何通讯。但还有广播。我们播出了吗？是的。我们准备好再次开始了。这是一个位于安克雷奇的电台，依靠备用发电机和一个破裂的发射机运行。费尔班克斯的电台接收到了那个信号并进行了转播。而朱诺的一名男子不知何故接收到了费尔班克斯的电台信号，拨通了西雅图的一家广播电台，并让
the broadcast play over the phone. The Boy Scout troop that went overnight to McQ Creek, Bill Noble would like to get a message if they are all right. Like that, a voice from Anchorage touched the lower 48, as saw in the city was still there. And soon, the degraded signal broadcast in Seattle was relayed and relayed again, until eventually, people across America, then around the world, heard the same woman's voice.
广播通过电话播放。童子军部队昨晚去了 McQ Creek，比尔·诺布尔想传个话，看看他们是否平安。就这样，来自安克雷奇的声音触及了美国本土 48 州，仿佛这座城市依然存在。很快，在西雅图广播的微弱信号被一次又一次地中继，最终，全美乃至全世界的人们都听到了同一个女人的声音。
We have word here that Mary Sweet is asked to contact her mother. Mother is at home. The president of that Anchorage radio station happened to be on a goodwill tour of Japan. And when he turned on a radio in Tokyo, he couldn't believe it. It was the voice of his own news girl back home. The woman's name was Jeanie Chance. John Mwell and the Brink and Players have her story. 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc
我们这里收到消息，玛丽·斯威特被要求联系她的母亲。母亲在家。那家安克雷奇广播电台的总裁当时正好在日本进行友好访问。当他在东京打开收音机时，他简直不敢相信。那是他家乡自己新闻女郎的声音。那个女人的名字叫珍妮·钱斯。约翰·穆勒姆和布林克剧团带来了她的故事。1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc
1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc 1 tbc
1 tbc 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh
1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh In 1964, Henkrit the fastest growing city in America. A generation earlier, it had been a frontier town without a single concrete building. Now, it had 100,000 people. But it was mostly military build-up and oil speculation. The city felt like a bubble that could pop. Alaska had only been a state for five years and is one man, but you had the feeling that
1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1 tbh 1964 年，安克雷奇是美国发展最快的城市。一代人之前，它还是一个连一栋混凝土建筑都没有的边境小镇。现在，它拥有 10 万人口。但这里主要是军事建设和石油投机。这座城市感觉就像一个随时会破灭的泡沫。阿拉斯加成为州才五年，作为一个人，你会有种感觉，
everything is temporary. We weren't all going to leave, but you know, we might. And that insecurity made every new construction feel monumental. It was a bit more proof to people that their city was real. Like the brand new JC Penny Building Downtown, this was one of the first big chain retailers to build in Alaska, and it was huge. And nothing said sophisticated civilization,
一切都是暂时的。我们并不是都要离开，但你知道，我们可能会。那种不安全感让每一处新建筑都显得意义非凡。这对人们来说是证明他们城市真实存在的又一点证据。就像市中心那栋全新的杰西潘尼大楼，这是首批在阿拉斯加建造的大型连锁零售商之一，而且规模巨大。没有什么比一座五层楼高的百货商店更能代表文明的崛起，
rising out of the wilderness, like a five-story department store, full of lingerie and blenders. ["Longer Ray and Blenders"] There were the beginnings of genuine culture in Anchorage, too, like the city's all-volunteer symphony conducted by a moon-lighting bulldozer operator. In the Anchorage Little Theater, a community troop run by a cosmopolitan guy
里面摆满了内衣和搅拌机。["内衣和搅拌机"] 安克雷奇也开始有了真正的文化，比如由一名兼职推土机操作员指挥的城市全志愿者交响乐团。在安克雷奇小剧院，一个由一位名叫弗兰克·布林克的时髦男人经营的社区剧团，
and a turtle neck, named Frank Brink. Brink found roles for everyone in his place, housewives, judges, air force officers, and he worked his actors hard, he just staged his own three-hour epic of a laskin history called Cry of the Wild Ram. I know it sounds a little bit like waiting for Guthman but they were good. Meanwhile covering all this life in the city were two daily newspapers and five local radio stations. One of them K E N I, Pride didided itself on being the biggest radio network in the biggest state in the union. And one of K-E-N-I's biggest honor personalities was a woman named Jeanie Chance. Jeanie was 37. She'd grown up poor in Bonham, Texas, then come to Alaska with her husband a few years earlier, looking for opportunity. They only sort of found it at first. He sold used cars and she watched their three kids at home.
他穿着高领毛衣。布林克为他的剧目里的每个人都找到了角色，家庭主妇、法官、空军军官，他对自己演员的要求很严格，他刚刚上演了他自己创作的关于阿拉斯加历史的三小时史诗剧《野公羊的呼喊》。我知道这听起来有点像《等待戈多》，但他们演得很好。与此同时，报道城市里所有这些生活的是两份日报和五家当地广播电台。其中一家 KENI 以身为这个联邦最大州里最大的广播网而自豪。而 KENI 最著名的主持人之一是一位名叫珍妮·钱斯的女性。珍妮 37 岁。她在德克萨斯州的博纳姆贫困长大，几年前和丈夫来到阿拉斯加寻找机会。起初他们只是勉强找到了机会。他卖二手车，她在家里照顾三个孩子。
But Jeannie loved radio, so she started working construction every morning in exchange for childcare, then go to work all afternoon at one of the local radio stations. Back then, women were usually made to cover cooking or fashion, but at KENI, Genie turned herself into a gutsy roving reporter, driving all over Alaska with a mobile broadcasting unit in her car.
但珍妮热爱广播，所以她每天早上开始做建筑工作以换取托儿服务，然后整个下午都在当地的一家广播电台工作。那时，女性通常被要求报道烹饪或时尚，但在 KENI，珍妮把自己变成了一名勇敢的流动记者，开着车带着移动广播设备跑遍阿拉斯加。
She flew with smoke jumpers, covered Arctic warfare exercises, reported from Inuit villages and crab boats. Her voice was part of the city. People trusted her, respected her in Anchorage, and in a way, women journalists weren't always respected in 1964. Later, a New York paper celebrated her as... In a Laskin' Housewife and mother of three children who does a man-sized job with a radio microphone.
她和伞兵一起飞行，报道北极战争演习，从因纽特村庄和捕蟹船上发回报道。她的声音是这座城市的一部分。人们信任她，在安克雷奇尊重她，而在 1964 年，女性记者并不总是受到尊重。后来，一家纽约报纸称赞她是……一位阿拉斯加家庭主妇和三个孩子的母亲，用广播麦克风做着男人做的工作。
A late in the afternoon of March 27th, Genie was driving her 13-year-old son to a bookstore downtown. It was good Friday and lots of people had already gone home from work for the Easter weekend. A banner across Fourth Avenue advertised that weekend's opening it, Frank Brink's Theatre. They were doing the Thornton Wilder play, our town. Curtain was going to go up at 8 o'clock, but at five thirty-six. She's first thought when her car started bucking at the red light was that she must have blown a tire. But then, through the windshield, she saw people knock down in the street. She saw a line of parked cars with the gas station slammed together,
3 月 27 日下午晚些时候，珍妮正开车带着她 13 岁的儿子去市中心的一家书店。那天是耶稣受难日，许多人已经下班回家准备复活节周末了。第四大道上的一条横幅广告宣传着那个周末弗兰克·布林克剧院的开幕演出。他们要演桑顿·怀尔德的剧作《我们的小镇》。大幕本应在 8 点拉开，但在 5 点 36 分。当她的车在红灯处开始颠簸时，她首先想到的是轮胎爆了。但随后，透过挡风玻璃，她看到人们在街上被撞倒。她看到一排停在加油站的汽车猛烈地撞在一起，
and separated, and slammed again. She watched them fold in and out and thought, it's like a grotesque accordion. Later, one man would say it felt like the earth was whipping the city around like a dog shaking an animal he's killed. Buildings listed off their foundations. The huge ground waves moved through the asphalt like the roads were liquid.
分开，又再次撞在一起。她看着它们折叠起来又展开，心想，这就像一个怪诞的手风琴。后来，有人说感觉大地像狗摇晃猎物一样在摇晃这座城市。建筑物从地基上滑落。巨大的地面波浪穿过沥青，仿佛道路变成了液体。
At the JC Penny Building of School's kids stuck in the elevator, watched a book suddenly levitate off the elevator floor and hang weightless in mid-air in front of him. For split second, it was like he wasn't a orbit. Suddenly levitate off the elevator floor and hang weightless in mid-air in front of it. For split second, it was like he wasn't a orbit, and that's when he knew the elevator was falling. Quake went on like this for almost five full minutes. Then stopped. did, Jeannie, through her car and gear. She was a reporter after all, and still not realizing how severe the situation was she raised to the police station to get a quick story for the evening broadcast.
在杰西潘尼大楼，被困在电梯里的孩子们看着一本书突然从电梯地板上悬浮起来，在他们面前失重地悬在半空中。那一瞬间，就像他不在轨道上一样。突然从电梯地板上悬浮起来，在面前失重地悬在半空中。那一瞬间，就像他不在轨道上一样，就在那时他知道电梯在下坠。地震就这样持续了近五分钟。然后停止了。珍妮扔下车和装备。毕竟她是一名记者，当时还没意识到情况有多严重，她冲向警察局，想为晚间广播搞到一条快讯。
Inside all the filing cabinets were thrown over, ceiling plaster heaped on the floor, then a second-chilled hit. And Genie's son, who'd gone off, came running around the corner, shouting, come quick, the pennies is falling down. An enormous concrete panel had shorn away from the JC pennies exterior in fallen. Now the entire building was sagging and running over.
里面所有的文件柜都被掀翻了，天花板的灰泥堆在地上，接着第二次余震袭来。珍妮的儿子跑过拐角，大喊道，快来，杰西潘尼大楼要塌了。一块巨大的混凝土板从杰西潘尼大楼的外墙脱落并坠落。现在整栋建筑都在下垂和倾斜。
Genie watched a second panel, lurch loose, and dropped with a roar. The scene was brutal. Ginny stepped around part of a body in the snow, a person split into by the falling debris. A Chevy station wagon was flattened, but you could hear a woman still alive inside, calling to the crowd trying to dig her out. Then Ginny rounded the corner, saw the whole impossible panorama. One entire side of fourth avenue had just dropped. For two blocks, everything was 12 or 15 feet
珍妮看着第二块板子松动，轰然坠落。现场惨不忍睹。珍妮绕过雪地里的一具残骸，那是一个被坠落碎片劈成两半的人。一辆雪佛兰旅行车被压扁了，但你能听到里面还有个女人活着，向试图挖掘她的人群呼救。然后珍妮转过拐角，看到了整个不可思议的全景。第四大道的一整侧刚刚塌陷。在两个街区的范围内，一切都下降了 12 或 15 英尺，
lower in a ravine that had opened under half the street. In the crazy part was buildings were still intact down there. Cars were still perfectly parked next to their meters. Men looked up from outside a bar, it doesn't treat underground like stunned miners. And still hanging there over the street, like a cruel caption over this surreal wreckage, was the theater banner that read our town.
落入在街道一半下方裂开的沟壑中。最疯狂的是，那里的建筑物竟然完好无损。汽车依然完美地停在停车计时器旁边。男人们从酒吧外抬头看，像惊呆的矿工一样看着地下。而依然悬在街上，像是在这超现实残骸上的一句残酷标题，是那条写着《我们的小镇》的剧院横幅。
The Quake Hennock Genannie's radio station off the air, but now the static on the transistor radio she was carrying suddenly gave way to music. It meant Kei and I was back. An engineer started talking and Jeannie grabbed the radio unit in her car and cut in. Go ahead, Jeannie. She was surprised later when people told her she sounded calm.
地震让珍妮的电台停播了，但现在她随身携带的晶体管收音机里的静电突然变成了音乐。这意味着 KENI 恢复了。一位工程师开始说话，珍妮抓起车里的广播设备切入进去。继续，珍妮。后来人们告诉她，她听起来很冷静，这让她很惊讶。
It has become obvious that the earthquake that struck Anchorage less than an hour ago is a major one. We urge each and every one of you to seek shelter, check your emergency supplies, and plan to keep your homes closed as much as possible so that you can retain the heat. Check your neighbors, see if they have transistor radios. If they don't possibly they could move in with you and share one for the heat. Check your neighbors see if they have transistor radios. If they don't possibly they could move in with you and share one for the night. It seems like it's going to be a long cold night for Anchorage so prepare to batten down the hatches and stay tuned to KENI. I think of what it means when we say a person feels shaken. In Anchorage, this wasn't a metaphor. The whole city had been thrown.
显而易见，不到一小时前袭击安克雷奇的地震是一场大地震。我们敦促你们每一个人寻找避难所，检查应急物资，并计划尽可能关闭房屋，以便保持热量。检查你的邻居，看看他们是否有晶体管收音机。如果他们没有，可能他们可以搬到你那里，共用一个收音机取暖。检查你的邻居，看看他们是否有晶体管收音机。如果他们没有，可能他们可以搬到你那里，共用一个收音机过夜。对于安克雷奇来说，这似乎将是一个漫长而寒冷的夜晚，所以准备好加固门窗，并继续收听 KENI。我想到了当我们说一个人感到“动摇”时意味着什么。在安克雷奇，这不仅仅是一个比喻。整座城市都被抛掷了。
There'd only been about an hour between the quake and nightfall, with the power out and snow falling through a thick fog in the dark. There was no way for everyone to tell just how badly their world had been jumbled. The feeling of vulnerability of total dislocation was hard to describe. This one guy put it, you don't know if anyone else is alive, maybe you were the last man. So it was comforting to hear another voice start talking to you, especially Jeanne Chancen's voice. After making that first announcement on the air, Jeanne drove back to the police station. Authorities realized that with the radio unit in her car, she was the only
地震发生到夜幕降临之间只有一个小时，电力中断，大雪在黑暗中穿过浓雾落下。没有人能说清他们的世界被搅乱到了什么程度。那种脆弱感、彻底的错位感很难描述。正如一个人所说，你不知道还有没有其他人活着，也许你是最后一个幸存者。所以听到另一个声音开始对你说话，尤其是珍妮·钱斯的声音，是很令人欣慰的。在广播中做出第一次公告后，珍妮开车回到了警察局。当局意识到，凭借她车里的广播设备，她是唯一一个
voice they were able to address the entire city. So they told her to keep talking. Soon they got her broadcasting from inside the building and rounded phone calls to her as the lines reopened, who was up to Jeannie to decide what information to relay to the public. At first it was mostly just her. One K-Yin andI employee remembers that the newscaster had been on the air when the Quake struck. A hot shot they just hired away from a big station in Los Angeles had been so weak out that the second that shaking stopped,
能够向全城讲话的声音。所以他们告诉她继续说。很快，他们让她在建筑物内进行广播，并在线路重新开通时将电话转接给她，由珍妮决定向公众传达什么信息。起初主要是她一个人。一位 KENI 的员工记得，地震发生时，那位新闻主播正在广播。一个刚从洛杉矶大电台高薪聘请来的“大人物”被吓坏了，地震一停，
he'd walked out of the building without a word. He resurfaced a couple weeks later, calling from back in California to officially quit. And Jeannie was shaken too. A week later, she'd break down out of nowhere and weep all night, but now... I kept trying to forget the unforgettable scenes I had witnessed. Thousands of terrified people were huddled in their unheated shelters, waiting for words of reassurance and instruction.
他一言不发地走出了大楼。几周后他重新出现，从加利福尼亚打来电话正式辞职。珍妮也受到了震动。一周后，她会毫无征兆地崩溃，整晚哭泣，但现在……我一直在努力忘记我所目睹的那些令人难忘的场景。成千上万惊恐的人们挤在没有暖气的避难所里，等待着安慰和指示的话语。
So she started doing her job, talking to people on the radio. Before long, the rest of her colleagues and other stations in town were back working the airwaves too, but still often felt like Jeannie was the one at the center of things, directing things. The turbine site needs diesel fuel, she'd say, or here's where electricians should report. And then she started reading the personal messages, pouring in too. Mr. and Mrs. Dick Fisher are still here
所以她开始做她的工作，在广播里和人们交谈。没过多久，她其他的同事和城里的其他电台也恢复了广播，但感觉依然像是珍妮处于中心，指挥着一切。涡轮机现场需要柴油，她说，或者这是电工应该报告的地方。然后她开始阅读涌入的个人信息。迪克·费舍尔夫妇还在警察总部，等待关于他们孩子的任何消息。我们收到西北航空公司的消息说，机组人员无法找到空姐贝弗利·约翰斯。太多人急于寻找或安慰彼此。霍华德·福布斯想让大家知道他会在迈克·惠特莫尔那里。珍妮正在帮助这些人在这座破碎的城市里呼喊。给肯尼斯·萨德勒的消息。萨德勒夫人很好。
at Police Headquarters waiting for any word of their children. We have a message from Northwest Airlines saying that the crew cannot locate stewardess Beverly Johns. So many people were desperate to locate or reassure each other. Howard Forbes would like it to be known that he will be at Mike Whitmore's. And Jeannie was helping those people shout across the fractured city. A message to Kenneth Sadler. Mrs. Sadler is fine.
给沃尔特·哈特的消息。李·哈特很好。给沃尔特·哈特的消息，李·哈特很好。与此同时，业余无线电操作员正在将这些信息转发给美国本土 48 州的家庭。当全国各地的记者终于联系上安克雷奇时，通常是珍妮，依然坐在她的广播麦克风前接听他们的电话。不，她保证城市没有被火焰吞没。不，这里没有实行戒严。她和奥马哈、纽约、伦敦通话。她做的一次采访当天就在其他 100 多个地方转播了。周五晚上变成了周六早上，然后是周六下午，周六晚上。
A message to Walter Hart. Lee Hart is fine. A message to Walter Hart, Lee Hart is fine. Meanwhile, Ham radio operators were relaying those messages to families in the lower 48. And when reporters around the country finally got through to Anchorage, it was often Jeanne, still sitting in front of her radio microphone who took their calls. No, she assured that the city wasn't swallowed in flames. And no, it wasn't under martial law. She talked to Omaha, New York, London. One interview she did was rebroadcast in more than 100 other places the same day. Friday night it becomes Saturday morning, then Saturday afternoon, Saturday night.
前 30 个小时我一直在不停地说话。睡了两个小时后，她又回到了广播里。也许值得停下来大声说出这一点。地震真是太糟糕了。但我的意思是，从存在主义的角度来看也是如此。想象一下，看着现实突然在你周围崩塌，看着你那充满完美直角的城市，这足以改变一个人的世界观，那一定像梦一样。50 多年后，一位安克雷奇的前市长告诉我，即使现在，我看着窗外这片坚实的土地，也知道它不是永久的。
For the first 30 hours I talked constantly. And after two hours sleep, she was right back on the air. It's probably worth stopping for a second to say this out loud. Earthquakes are fucked up. But I mean in an existential way too. Imagine how dreamlike it must have been, watching reality suddenly buckle around you, watching your city of infallible right angles, and who is enough to change a person's worldview. More than 50 years later, a former mayor of Anchorage told me, Even now, I can look at this solid ground out the window and know that it's not permanent.
它随时会变。它只是在移动。一切都在移动。要明白，在 1964 年，板块构造论还只是一个理论。一种相当激进的理论。人们很难接受我们所站立的大陆实际上是在运动的。它们只是在剧烈碰撞的岩石板块上随机滑动，没有什么东西是稳定的。一切都纯粹靠运气。
It can change anytime. It just moves. Everything moves. Understand that in 1964, plate tectonics was still just a theory. Kind of a radical one. It was hard for people to accept that the continents we stand on are actually in motion They were just sliding around randomly on violently colliding plates of rock and that nothing is stable That everything runs on pure chance
这正是这个故事真正的主题：运气。也许这很明显。甚至这个女人的姓氏也是如此。但问题是，我们该如何生活在如此难以忍受的随机性表面上？我们能抓住什么？它是固定的。但当我听到那个周末珍妮在广播里的旧录音，以及所有其他也在努力工作的人的声音时，一幅画面浮现在脑海中：它们是坚实的物体，就像电线穿过安克雷奇市和阿拉斯加州更远的地方。它们也相互交叉，像一张网，一种替代的人类基础设施，在建筑环境崩塌的地方连接起来。
That's what this story is about really chance Maybe that's obvious. It's even the woman's last name is about really chance. Maybe that's obvious, it's even the woman's last name. But the question is, how are we supposed to live on the surface of such unbearable randomness? What can we grab hold of? It's fixed. But when I hear the old recordings of Jeannie on the radio that weekend and all the other voices working to, a picture of them is solid objects, like wires crossing the city of Anchorage and the state of Alaska further out. Crossing each other too, like a net, kind of alternate human infrastructure, snapping into where the built environment gave way.
我能听到鲍勃，然后我会把它转回给你。圣公会教堂的 18 到 F 是临时关闭的。弗兰克·布林克，今天的一名表演者，Mu 在 Piles 9 有两个人的住宿。任何有空余的人，需要一个成员。下日本航空公司的飞机。OVC 在你来的路上。一个非常有趣的人。我会让一些人告诉我们关于你那里的损失。这是此时此刻，评估这里正在发生什么。三个男孩，最后一站。红布一定是你们俱乐部里的第一个。
I can hear Bob and then I'll turn it right back to you. The Episcopal Church of 18 to F is temporary shot. Frank Brink, a drominaparmino today, a Mu has accommodations for two people at Piles 9 on the Anybody who has a spare spare, need a member. Get off the Japanese Airlines. The OVC is on your way. A very interesting person. I'd make some tell us about some of the damage out at your name. This is one of this time, right now, to evaluate what is happening here. Three boys, right last stop. The red cloths must be the first that you're clubbing.
如果你想要铁路，当然，一定要走进去。铁路，你想要更多人联系埃尔顿，德国。铁路将挤满小城市。另一个是 At the meal，你的亲戚在安克雷奇都很好。侧面建筑。好的，你们都很好。我想把它扔在街上。
If you want the railroad, you course, be sure to walk in. The railroad, you would like more as to contact Elton, Germany. The railroad is going to be full of small cities. The other is the At the meal, you're relatives and Anchorage are all right. Side to building. Okay, you're all right. I want to throw it on the street.
我想把它扔在街上。这会更有趣一点。我不能过去。有北方酒店。消息说你的家人已经被联系上了，一切都好。我一直忙于协助这里的消息服务协调工作，在 Chivaldi Fentx 总部，我真的还没停下来想过我的父母该有多担心和焦虑。我知道费尔班克斯的 KFAR 正在监控我们，并正在向南方的 48 州转发消息。
I want to throw it on the street. It's going to be a little bit more fun. I can't go by. Have the Northern Hotel. The message says your family has been contacted and everything is okay. I've been so involved trying to assist down here in the coordination of the message service at the Chivaldi Fentx Headquarters that I really hadn't stopped to think how worried and concerned my parents must be. I understand that KFAR and Fairbank is monitoring us and is relaying messages to the South 48.
我想知道 KFAR 的人是否能帮我记下一条消息，并告诉我在德克萨斯州博纳姆的家人，钱斯一家都很好。钱斯一家都很好。我们五个人都平安。我们谁都没受一点伤。我们还有一分钟听你说话。为了什么？（此处省略重复的符号）
I wonder if the person in KFAR would take down a message for me and get the word to my family in Bonham, Texas, that the chance family is all right. The chance family is all right. All five of us are safe. None of us received a scratch. We have another minute to hear you. And for what? ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ ʻ‿ʻ‿ʻ Late on Saturday, the day after the quake, Jeannie read a list of the missing and dead on the air. No one told her to do it, but there didn't seem to be anyone to ask for permission either. The next day was Easter Sunday. Ministers talked about death and resurrection, a staff of the Anchorage Daily Times picked
周六晚些时候，地震发生后的第二天，珍妮在广播中读了一份失踪和死亡名单。没有人让她这么做，但似乎也没有人可以去请求许可。第二天是复活节周日。牧师们谈论着死亡与复活，安克雷奇日报的员工捡起
up all the pieces of movable type thrown all over their printing room, managed to put out a newspaper. To JC Penny executives declared, we will build again bigger and better than before. And eventually the little theater resumed its production of our town too. One of the actors told me that after the quake, whenever a restaurant and anchorage reopened or a church held a mass, there was never an empty seat, he said. Everyone wanted to be with someone else. And there was something especially poetic about the sold-out crowd at the theater that
散落在印刷室各处的活字，设法印出了一份报纸。杰西潘尼的高管宣布，我们将重建，比以前更大更好。最终，小剧院也恢复了《我们的小镇》的演出。一位演员告诉我，地震后，每当安克雷奇的一家餐馆重新开业或教堂举行弥撒时，座位从来没有空过，他说。每个人都想和别人在一起。而那个在剧院里座无虚席的观众群，有着某种特别的诗意，
first night. Because that kind of togetherness is basically what Thornton Wilders plays about. It's play about daily life in a small town, the deaths and marriages, tragedies, births, and how, under all that flux, there's stability to every community over time. In Anchorage, a city that worried it was temporary, realized it was temporary, at least all its buildings and houses and roads, but it was discovering there was something permanent about itself too. All night at the theater, the character of the stage manager talked to the audience directly narrating the story of the play, kind of like I've been doing tonight.
第一晚。因为那种团结正是桑顿·怀尔德剧作的主题。这是一部关于小镇日常生活的戏，死亡与婚姻、悲剧、诞生，以及在所有这些变迁之下，随着时间的推移，每个社区都有其稳定性。在安克雷奇，这座担心自己是暂时的城市，意识到它是暂时的，至少它所有的建筑、房屋和道路都是如此，但它也发现自己身上也有某种永久的东西。整晚在剧院里，舞台经理的角色直接与观众交谈，讲述剧中的故事，就像我今晚所做的那样。
Now when the curtain rose on the final act, he came out for his monologue and told them. Now, there are some things we all know, but we don't take them out and look at them very often. We all know that something is eternal, and it ate houses, and it ate names, and it ate earth, and it ate even stars. Everybody knows in their bones that something is eternal, and that something has to do with human beings. All the greatest people ever lived have been taught as that for 5,000 years, and yet you'd be surprised
现在，当最后一幕大幕拉开时，他走出来进行独白，告诉他们。现在，有些事情我们都知道，但我们不常拿出来看。我们都知道有些东西是永恒的，它吞噬了房屋，吞噬了名字，吞噬了大地，甚至吞噬了星星。每个人骨子里都知道有些东西是永恒的，而那东西与人类有关。有史以来最伟大的人们 5000 年来一直被教导这一点，然而你会惊讶于
how people are always losing hold of it. In the end, Jeannie Chan stayed on duty, K and I for 59 hours that weekend. When things finally calmed down, she sat down to write a letter to her parents in Texas. They'd written to her right after the quake pleading with Jeannie to send her three kids to live with them, while that battered city up in Alaska figured out what's next. Think of the kids' safety, they said. In part of Jeannie thought it was a good idea, but then she had another more convincing thought.
人们总是如何失去对它的把握。最后，珍妮·钱斯那个周末在 KENI 值班了 59 个小时。当事情终于平静下来时，她坐下来给德克萨斯的父母写了一封信。地震后他们立刻写信给她，恳求珍妮把三个孩子送到他们那里住，而阿拉斯加那个饱受摧残的城市还在想下一步该怎么办。想想孩子们的安全，他们说。珍妮的一部分觉得这是个好主意，但随后她有了另一个更有说服力的想法。
We must be together. As long as we're together, we are confident of the future. That was a good idea, but then she had another more convincing thought. We must be together. As long as we are together, we are confident of the future. She explained to her parents. That good Friday night, I knew we had survived miraculously. And for this reason, there must be a purpose to our lives. Apparently, the children must sense this too, for they have remained calm. They have been fully aware of the emergency, but have not feared. We are proud that they
我们必须在一起。只要我们在一起，我们就对未来充满信心。那是个好主意，但随后她有了另一个更有说服力的想法。我们必须在一起。只要我们在一起，我们就对未来充满信心。她向父母解释。那个耶稣受难日的晚上，我知道我们奇迹般地幸存了下来。因此，我们的生命一定有某种目的。显然，孩子们一定也感觉到了这一点，因为他们一直保持冷静。他们完全意识到紧急情况，但并没有感到恐惧。我们很自豪他们
are such dependable, responsible youngsters. I would not undermine their confidence in the future, in themselves, by sending them away for their safety. What is safety anyway? How can you predict where or when tragedy will occur? You can only learn to live with it and make the best of it when it happens. These children are not afraid. Their father and I are not afraid. Please don't you fear for us. What is safety anyway? Genie seemed to be conceding that there is only randomness, only chance. And if everything beyond us is chance, maybe the only force we have to survive a world like that is connection.
是如此可靠、负责任的年轻人。我不会通过为了安全而把他们送走，来削弱他们对未来、对自己的信心。什么是安全呢？你怎么能预测悲剧会在何时何地发生？你只能学会与它共存，并在它发生时尽力而为。这些孩子们不害怕。他们的父亲和我也不害怕。请不要为我们担心。什么是安全呢？珍妮似乎承认只有随机性，只有运气。如果超越我们的一切都是运气，也许我们在这样的世界中生存的唯一力量就是联系。
But then it must have seemed so obvious to her's a good idea to hold on to each other. Thank you. John Moelleum, the break players, Jenny Conley Driesos, on a coordinate piano, Nate Creary on bass, John Moelleun on drums, John Moan on drums, Chris Fung on guitar, and John Newfield also on guitar. And that is Miss Avery Troubleman as Cheney Channets. Thank you. 99% Invisible was recorded at the More Theater in Seattle on the radio topia live west coast tour
但那时，坚持在一起对她来说一定显得如此显而易见。谢谢。约翰·穆勒姆，布林克剧团，珍妮·康利·德里索斯在协调钢琴上，内特·克里里在贝斯上，约翰·穆勒姆在鼓上，约翰·莫恩在鼓上，克里斯·冯在吉他上，约翰·纽菲尔德也在吉他上。那是艾弗里·特鲁布尔曼小姐饰演珍妮·钱斯。谢谢。《99% Invisible》是在西雅图莫尔剧院录制的，在 Radio Topia 西海岸巡演期间。
We were lucky enough to be joined in the audience by several members of genie chants's family who came from Alaska and Texas to see it Which is why I nearly cried at the end of the story we were directed by Lynn Finkel post-production mixed by Sean Rial and Sriviusi words by John Moellum and music by the bring Flare. The rest of the crew is Katie Mingle Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, and Terran Mazza. This music right here is by Sean Ria. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
我们很幸运，观众中有几位珍妮·钱斯的家人，他们从阿拉斯加和德克萨斯赶来看演出，这就是为什么我在故事结尾差点哭了。我们由林恩·芬克尔导演，后期制作由肖恩·里亚尔和斯里维乌西混音，约翰·穆勒姆撰稿，布林克剧团配乐。其余工作人员是凯蒂·明格尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、德莱尼·霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和泰兰·马扎。这段音乐是由肖恩·里亚尔创作的。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在 Radio Row 制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. California. in popular stories. Visit our website at 99piod.org. Radio to PO. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。加利福尼亚。在热门故事中。访问我们的网站 99piod.org。Radio Topia。来自 PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。